welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and we just got a trailer for
uncharted the upcoming film based on the
game franchise from naughty dog starring
tom holland as treasure hunter nathan
drake mark wahlberg as his partner sully
but no mustache because how can i keep
talking fast with a mustache stash slows
me down baby i gotta kiss your mother
with this mouth that's right everyone is
in love with these casting choices but
no i am eager to check out this trailer
to see for myself how they adapt the
uncharted games games that i played when
i was younger but i honestly don't
remember a lot of that those were the
dark times before i viewed my nerdiness
as a strength but yeah i'm gonna react
to this trailer give my honest initial
impressions and explain what this movie
is and a few details that you might have
missed from this trailer cool here we
go
what are they doing
why did sony always do the teaser to the
trailer just start with the trailer
anyway there are places out there you
can't find on any map that sounds like
the music from the uncharted games
looks like he's with chloe there
playstation
is this led zeppelin hello young for a
bartender aren't you a little old for
prom aren't you yeah
yeah it sounds like they're using ramble
on
i don't think you don't need this music
this path for magellan took the sail
around the world you know your history
yeah that's never been found five
billion easy
[Music]
we got the ring in there that's a big
deal
all right
good
yeah they don't need this music it's not
crazy
sally doesn't have any friends i should
know i'm one of them
you are a collector well i dabble i
don't know
my family has been looking for this
fortune for a very long time so much
blood
okay
cool i'm pretty sure he's just
threatening to kill me don't touch your
ear like that you look like an
idiot is that a casino royale joke
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother say i'm off
one final clue who is sam gonna be
oh are they doing the this is from
the third game i think
oh cool
oh sweet
oh that looks great
oh this is cool okay i'm digging that
not digging the music but that man that
plane
being because you're crashed to get a
proper scottish welcome
what
that's good
oh crap that's the line he did it he
said the thing
okay
you know what we needed we needed a bit
of a tom cruise mummy yeah
as he fell there okay promising i have
some concerns but promising i mean a bit
of background on the uncharted games if
you're not familiar the games follow the
treasure hunter nathan drake nate drake
played by tom holland in this movie but
this movie has been in development for
years originally there's a big push to
have nathan fillion play nathan drake i
mean he really is dream casting in that
role like i was born to play that role
he might be a bit too old for it now but
i would love if they could bring him
into this franchise somehow uh actually
i think like 10 years ago they were
gonna have mark wahlberg play this
character in a version of the movie
directed by david o russell and they're
gonna have robert de niro play sully
that would have been
weird and i'm kind of glad it never
happened but it does explain i guess why
marky mark is now in this role as sully
refuses to get a mustache but i assume
he'll uh don a mustache at some point in
this movie he better there better be
some picture of him with a mustache but
the appeal of these games is that
they've always uh kind of evoked those
cinematic tropes of the treasure hunter
genre right so indiana jones the brendan
fraser mummy movie national treasure in
the games uh voice actor nolan north one
of the great voices nathan drake i
actually got to meet nolan north i
interviewed him when he appeared on a
rick and morty after show that we did
he's a really great guy he just brings
in this natural swagger and charm and i
think what we love about tom holland is
in his portrayal of peter parker he's a
smart guy and he commits so hard to the
stunts but what's so lovable about his
version of peter parker is he's just
kind of a dope like he doesn't have that
street smarts he's so slow on the uptake
despite being a brilliant engineer who
has spidey sense however we've already
started to see tom holland tackle meteor
roles like his role in cherry the devil
all the time and i think he can totally
pull off this role he just seems a
little young right now but that's what
they're doing they're doing an origin
story this video is brought to you by
privacy privacy lets you buy things
online using virtual cards protecting
your identity and bank information on
the internet as a treat for my viewers
new customers get five dollars to spend
on their first purchase when they go to
privacy.com new rockstars to sign up now
privacy makes it super easy to manage
your financial lives online while
keeping all of your information secure
by generating virtual numbers privacy
masks your bank information so you never
have to worry about giving it out to
those baddies lurking behind the
internet corners it's easy to share
cards with friends and family using
privacy's shared cards parents can set
caps on how much the kids can spend and
businesses can send cards with spending
limits to employees for company expenses
i like privacy for recurring payments
like streaming services like i've set up
a privacy account i've linked my bank
account i created a card specifically
for my netflix subscription payment
privacy will ding me if someone tries to
charge the card twice or if the charge
exceeds the amount you set for it and if
i want to plan to cancel my subscription
a couple months ahead i can just do all
that ahead of time and then the card
expires and i don't have to remember to
cancel it's awesome fill out your credit
card info in the privacy.com chrome and
firefox extension and you're one click
away from spending smartly and safely
head to privacy.com new rockstars and
sign up for an account new customers
will automatically get five dollars to
spend on your first purchase so go to
privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now this seems
like it's pulling a lot from the fourth
uncharted game in which the mystery of
nate's brother sam comes up although
this airplane cargo lily pad jump is
exactly what you have to do at one point
in the third game it looks really cool
here i'm really glad that they're
including it it's kind of like what they
do in resident evil you know they kind
of pull bits and pieces from different
games and put them all in a movie but
the movie is really kind of its own
thing i don't mind them doing that with
uncharted because uncharted is already
so steeped in the kind of lore and
tropes that we saw in indiana jones so
for them to just make another indiana
jones style movie out of this i don't
feel like it's sacrilege although i do
hope it has that kind of sacred respect
of the beyond that the indiana jones
movies do that's my concern with this
movie and really with all movies these
days is that they are not willing to go
as dark as the original indiana jones
movies did like raiders of lost ark ends
by blowing up and melting nazis using
the power of god the second one
basically started the whole npaa debate
over how movies should be raided when
you had characters getting their hearts
ripped out and they were burned alive
the last crusade has them sipping from
the holy grail and turning into a dusty
skeleton and what's cool about the
uncharted games is they do usually go in
that supernatural direction like you
find out that there are zombies on an
island maroon there from world war ii i
hope this movie goes in that dark
direction i truly do but going through
this trailer it looks like it opens with
uh nate on um a side mission with chloe
character who comes into the franchise
in the second game i believe i wonder if
this movie's gonna open the way raiders
lost ark does on this kind of side
mission which oh hey uh featured alfred
molina tom holland's co-star in
spider-man no way home that was him that
was one of his early roles i mean i
think it's great when these stories just
start in the heat of the action right
and if you listen closely this is the
music a piano version from the uncharted
games and i wish that that score was the
music they kind of stick with because
while i love led zeppelin i love ramble
on it just feels like totally out of
place with this this just feels like a
classic sony move with these trailers
it's bringing a random popular song but
i'm guessing they're going for the
formula that was successful for them
with the new jumanji reboots right
jumanji welcome to the jungle jumanji
the next level which both prominently
feature these ac dc songs and they kind
of figure well we'll have like this
indiana jones adventure aesthetic while
bringing in a popular rock song and they
think by bringing in classic rock that
will help the formula here but it
doesn't need it so again this is going
to be the origin story of how sully and
nate meet by tracking down uh ferdinand
magellan's lost treasure treasure that
nate's brother sam has been chasing
after now the question is gonna be and i
think finding and reconnecting with his
brother sam is gonna be the true
treasure that nate is trying to pursue
making all of us ask sam's gonna be some
fun cameo right and the way that uh
jumanji welcome to the jungle there were
some surprise cameos in that movie so
who do you think sam's going to be
played by i'm guessing it's going to be
someone like andrew garfield i think
it'd be a really fun choice i mean i i
obviously intro garfield to maguire i
want those guys to be in no way home but
just to throw garfield in this movie he
already has a relationship with sony
i think it'd be fun now what's
interesting is ferdinand magellan is the
great explorer who is credited for uh
circumnavigating the globe magellan
himself did not make it all the way back
to portugal right his expedition one of
his other ships did make it back he
however died in the east indies in the
melee archipelago modern day philippines
so now it looks like this movie's laura
is explaining that there's some kind of
like billion dollar treasure i actually
wonder if antonio bandera is his
character who's going to be like the
rival treasure hunter the villain of
this which is another common trope from
these kind of movies he may be a
descendant of ferdinand magellan antonio
banderas is a spanish actor he mentions
his family has been looking for this
treasure for uh years he may feel like
this is his birthright and it looks like
they are planning a heist from an
auction of this one artifact this cross
with an interesting hatch mark halfway
through it almost like this could be a
key actually later we see nate and chloe
doing this double turn of what looks
like a key i wonder if this cross
actually serves that function it could
have a twin and it reminds me a lot of
the cross of coronado from indiana jones
the last crusade we see nate reading
this postcard from his brother sent from
san sebastian that's in spain there's a
whole world you haven't seen but you
will promise s and then using the
lighter he reveals this hidden ink
saying the blank are you coming so i
think he found this new clue and that's
what leads him on this journey now
there's a lot of focus in this trailer
on this ring this is a big easter egg
from the games that's used throughout
the games it's the ring of sir francis
drake that nathan drake thinks he is a
descendant of sir francis strike being
the the great explorer and pirate this
ring is a big deal it actually shows up
as an easter egg in the last of us part
two now we learned later in the games
that he is not an actual descendant
because uh sir francis drake never had
any children and nathan just kind of
adopted the name in order to pay tribute
to his hero like many scoundrels do in
indiana jones he named himself after the
dog we named the dog and tiana what's
that i i can't understand scottish
accents it's not that hard to understand
on this screen is the latin phrase sick
harvest magna greatness from small
beginnings and on it is the date january
29th 1596 which nate finds is the date
after sir francis drake died thinking
that he might have faked his own death
their ring is useless as like a decoder
ring to unlock puzzles throughout the
game i hope they use it in that kind of
way in the movies at the end of the
trailer we see this red mercedes pushing
nate out of the plane as he says nathan
drake's big line from the games oh crap
crap crap crap oh crap
this is the car that we see antonio
banderas character driving earlier on in
the trailer so this must be his supply
plane as they're both racing to this
next area and it looks like they will
find magellan's lost treasure on the
ship that is hidden in this cave kind of
like the ship of one-eyed willy in the
goonies i think we also see this ship at
the end of a thief's hand the fourth
game but i honestly don't have a problem
with tom holland in this role i think
people too often typecast actors just
based off of what they're more famously
known as the job of the actor is to act
to emulate new roles to transform
themselves and i think tom holland is
fully capable of doing that if anything
i i'm less crazy about mark wahlberg
playing sully i think that would have
been a fun role for nathan fillion to
play but i think a lot of people play
video games are hoping for one movie to
fully capture the experience of playing
a video game a true adaptation that is
super successful and like wins awards i
don't know if this movie will do that i
think it might do a better job than the
resident evil series did i think the
mortal kombat movie that came out this
past year was really fun it didn't have
the tournament in it but it at least
stayed true to the sentiment and the
mythology of the games and the fighting
was amazing the violence was sick i
think ultimately what uncharted is
trying to do is just create a new
indiana jones franchise which i'm okay
with i don't have a problem with i think
people who didn't play uncharted will
probably enjoy this movie ultimately the
naughty dog game series adaptation that
i'm most excited about is the last of us
on hbo just because the last of us is
already such a cinematic experience they
don't have to do that much to make it a
great miniseries on hbo i think it's
gonna be fantastic but let me know your
thoughts on this trailer do you think
it's gonna be a good movie who would you
cast in these roles and also because new
rockstars has done a bit of gaming
content in the past we'd love to do more
of it but we want to hear from you guys
what you want to see us do what kind of
gaming content would you like to see
more from us what kind of content do you
think we could contribute to what's here
on youtube already and reminder that you
can support new rockstars by checking
out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love and thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you